so this is obi-wan Kenobi he's a
Netherlands dwarf rabbit with the sensor
his hand it's a lot easier to manipulate
the wing of the duck and be confident
that I'm not hurting it on screen you
can basically see what the sensors are
picking up imagine robot fingers that
can actually feel they can feel textures
temperatures and vibrations sounds like
science fiction but it's real for years
we have been developing machines
designed to mimic human tasks and
behaviors with ever-increasing levels of
success
we now have machines to harvest our food
vacuum our floors and even drive our
cars but what about one of the most
fundamental elements that makes us human
what about a robotic hand that can feel
I myself an a congenital amputee which
means I was born with one hand in
elementary school I had a giant metal
hook and it was just big shiny and
silver and it opens like this and it was
basically a giant pirate hook like
Captain Hook wears as I grew older I
definitely found myself being a lot more
shy about it I would always find a
reason to take it off my whole idea of
the ideal prosthetic hand is one where
you don't realize you're wearing a
prosthetic hand and it just functions as
a hand
a robotic finger would be very helpful
specifically for me just because it
would make my prosthetic hand which is
essentially a dummy hand it would just
make it smarter and intuitive the bio
tag is a biomimetic tactile sensor
modeled after the human fingertip it's
capable of sensing everything that your
finger can detect so the reason we went
to biomimetic design is just an
appreciation for nature the human hand
represents billions of years of
evolution and that's something that
needs to be recreated synthetically in
order to mimic
sense of touch the bio tag fingertips
are equipped with human-like fingernails
because your nails are key in sensing
the tangential forces applied to the
surface of your finger pads fingerprints
also play an essential role in tactile
sensations by enhancing vibrations as
they slide over different textures also
a bone like core and inflated skin that
gives it a compliance and deformation
similar to a human finger tap when
you're using a prosthetic hand as
opposed to a normal hand you have to pay
attention to the amount of force you're
applying than any object with contact
detection it allows you to pay
significantly less attention to
manipulating fragile objects like an egg
than with nonsense Erised prosthetic
hand
with eggs it's just nice to know you're
not going to crack them it would take me
so much longer to multitask when cooking
eggs then I just did it's just way more
convenient it's going to make using the
prosthetic hand I have now easier and
more intuitive it's basically going to
allow me to move through my day quicker
and faster and more like someone who has
two hands when Vikram is making an
omelet it's not like he's doing
something impossible for somebody with a
simple mechanical prosthesis the
difference is that he can actually enjoy
it because his hand is reflexes and can
act on its own just like our biological
hands do with each new sense we learn to
engineer we come closer to robotics that
can truly recreate the human experience
check out more episodes of cyborg nation
by subscribing to the wired Channel